hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021 my name is camille and i'm
very happy to be your host for this
session
i would like now to welcome
barasita with us welcome yes you
pronounce it correctly
the first time
and
neil is going to give a talk to us on
notebook to production and is a data
scientist at uh dax hub
yeah
that's me
cool so uh let's just wait another
moment before we start so everyone can
join us so i see that we have visitors
from copenhagen and and the uk so it's
amazing to see uh the turnout for this
session um
and i want to say that i'm actually very
excited being here today and honored to
talking with you it was great working on
this session this is something that i've
been researching at my job
so it was a lot of fun researching about
it and i want to also thank pi data
global for having me today and giving me
the privilege to speak with you
so i think we're ready to get started so
today's session is going to deal with
notebook to production and what do i
mean by that we're going to focus on how
we can reduce the iteration time from
the research phase to deploying our
model to production
and with that let's start with a quick
introduction of myself so my name is i'm
a data scientist at dagda and apparently
i'm 82 confidence of being a person um
and i would consider myself as a
all-around team player with a varied
background so i'm combining machine
learning algorithms development with
finite element analysis and something
that i'm very passionate about and i
really love doing which is public
speaking
and i'm currently pursuing my master's
in data science and machine learning
from the raihman university here in
israel and i'm researching for the best
envelopes practices at my job at texas
and i would say that so far the
hypothesis that had the highest
statistical significance is that the
best way to get data scientist attention
is by using three phrases which is
notebook production and envelopes and
today today we will have them all
so in our session today i'd like to
explore how we can
reduce the time between um
the research phase using notebooks to
deploy in our model to production
and we'll try to use various envelopes
tools and techniques to do so
and implementing the
product playbook i'd like to start our
journey at the end zone i'd like to
think uh what will be our considerations
when deploying the model to production
and i don't mean accuracy
so the first thing that comes to my mind
when i'm thinking about production is
that i'm delivering a product to a
different team so this thing can be
inside my company or outside the company
therefore i want my model to be as
reliable as possible and in many cases
explainable
i also like to reduce the risk in bugs
for bugs in production therefore our
product should be testable and i know i
don't only mean our code but also our
data our model our pipeline basically
all the different components
and when a bike arises in production and
probably we
we want a way to reproduce the uh
production state and i don't mean only
have access to each of the uh component
but also to the relevant version that we
currently have in production
and last
we'd want to
make the process of deploying a new code
model pipeline to production as
automatic as possible to reduce the
friction between the research team and
the mlx team
and based on those considerations i
would learn to go back to the starting
point and usually when we start a new
project we're gonna test and prototype
our hypothesis and our go to tool is
probably gonna be notebooks
so jupiter project was born out of the
ipython in 2014 and has rapidly grown in
uh popularity among data scientists and
it became the de facto tool for
exploratory analysis and if you want to
be more data centric as andrea like to
say
so google searches uh since 2014 show a
clear trend jupiter notebook to the moon
and to give you a sense of its impact uh
twitter was awarded the acm 2017
software system award which is a very
very prestigious honor that it shares
with java unix and the web
however if you're going to explore some
of the data science communities or to be
more specific the envelopes community
communities you might get the impression
that the notebooks are all that is evil
in the world and i argue that i think
that notebooks are awesome
well notebooks is a great tool that
after all gives us superhuman abilities
they give us an interactive way to
work with our code and many companies
dags have included are choosing to use
notebooks interface to host their
tutorials and interactive menus
they also have built-in visualization
meaning that they are reactive and you
can see the result right after you run
the code that generated them and this is
also benefit for communicating our wall
with our colleagues that are technical
or with not so technical stakeholders
and all of this means that jupiter
notebooks are really great for quick
prototyping
however when your project evolves and
grows in complexity not to mention when
you're trying to deploy to production
you most likely hit the wall
and based on the research that we've
done at dagz up interviewing more than
150 data science practitioners and
machine learning engineers worldwide
we met the core difficulties that data
scientists face
so first and foremost as we all know
notebooks can run sporadically making us
put a lot of effort in tracking the
kernel state
when executing a new experiment and even
harder to reproduce the result of that
experiment
also collaborating so sharing and
collaborating are messy and not
straightforward but very often required
and also version control so i don't know
if
but these jupiter notebooks are
basically a very large json
and if they can
not be easily version and diff so there
are some tools that can help us in the
process but currently their usage is ad
hoc
another thing that notebooks has a
debugger tool but as the notebook gets
longer it becomes a really pain to use
it
and last oh the code that is hosted on
the notebook um so it's not callable
outside of the notebook therefore we
can't easily test it and also we can't
easily reuse it in our product or in
different projects
so
i will just know that if you face um any
more difficulties that i didn't mention
here i'd love to hear about them so you
can write it here on the chat and we
i'll review it after the session or you
can write me on the slack channel on the
pi data stack channel and i would love
to hear about that this is something
that we're researching about and i
really want to know what are the pains
for data scientists when using notebooks
so really feel free to reach out i would
love to hear about them
so
um i would say that some even go as far
as deploying their notebook to
production which i think is highly not
recommended so first and foremost there
are no proper ci ct tools for to do that
they also required a significant cleanup
and packaging of libraries which are
devops skills outside of our data
science scope or toolkit
and less jupiter notebooks are not a
team player so they don't play well with
other tools and
it may not be very easy to deploy your
jupyter notebook to production while
using other tools
so
now some of you might tell me but hey
wait what are you talking about netflix
twitter there are many companies that
are actually deploying their notebooks
to production well
you're right they are doing it but my
answer here will be that in 99.9
of cases you're not at the same scale
and don't have the resources needed to
build and support such workflow and if
you want to take uh netflix as an
example then netflix have built an
entire orchestration for deploying
notebooks to production and they're
almost using it as a service so this is
how much resource you need in order to
support such workflow
and now that we understand uh what are
the challenges when using notebooks
let's think about how we can overcome
them so i've gathered some of the best
practices currently using the industry
and constructed them into a structured
workflow that is based on five main
components
once again if i'm not talking or not
mentioning some of the components that
you're using i'd love to hear about it
so the first one and i would say the
core component is to convert our codes
to functions hosted in scripts outside
of the notebook and import them back to
the note
secondly to use the monorepo structure
to reduce complexity and scalar wall
to version
everything so not only our code but also
our data our model our pipeline and
basically all of the major project
components
we people like to track our experiments
in a way that will aid us to understand
the work and enable to other people to
review
our high level results
and last but not least and this is
something that is very important we want
to write functions to all of the project
components which will reduce the risk
for bugs in production
so
with that uh let's dive into each of the
components to better understand what
capabilities we're gonna gain by
implementing them
so in our use case uh our team lee just
got off the phone with the board and
there is a new project in the funnel
save the world and they just send us the
data set and obviously as we all know
they want a model in production
so we're probably going to open a
jupiter notebook and start getting our
feet wet and this is how our project is
going to look like so we'll have our
data set and this jupiter notebook
and our initial step will probably be
going to be exploring the data
and for example we're going to check for
a future distribution so in this case
we're going to check the distribution of
global warming
and this where the
most important conceptual chain comes
that that we need to make after getting
the initial piece of code to do what it
was intended to do
you need to refactor it into a python
function that relay only on global
variables and take everything as so this
is very important and this is the core
conceptual change that we need to make
okay
and now our code would look like
something like this so it's a function
hosted in a script outside of the
notebook and it gets only uh uh argument
and use them
and now we're gonna simply import the
script to our jupiter notebook and give
it the uh
the variables that it needs in order to
plot the distribution okay and this is
very important because now we can
uh write unit tests so we're going to
talk about what we're going to gain out
of it but this is very important to do
so by implementing that we're going to
simply add another python strip to a
project which is plot outliers or plot
distribution whatever
by and by implementing this flow we're
going to gain three main capabilities so
first and foremost we will be able to
run unit tests on the functions to make
sure that we don't fail in production
which is very important and a lot of
data scientists don't give it the
attention that it needs
also we're going to stay dry meaning
that we don't repeat ourselves we can
now easily reuse the code in this
project or anywhere else in other
project very easily
and we can use static code analysis
tools to flag programming ao's bugs and
many more which is a a good practice for
developing code
i know that we made our project much
more uh modular and we want to leverage
it and become more scalable and i would
do that by implementing the good
old-fashioned model repos tragedy
so monorepo is a trunk based development
uh implementation
meaning that uh we're gonna host code
for many projects under the same
repository and each sub project is gonna
have its own subdirectory
and well-known companies uses these
strategies such as
google facebook microsoft airbnb and
many many more
and you're probably going to ask
yourself or me
so wait what does it really got to do
with data science project so i argue
that quite a lot
so data science project can be divided
into
stages where each one is completely
independent of the other so we have our
exploratory data analysis we have our
data processing we have our modeling and
each one is independent and if we gonna
address
each step as independent component
will be able to divide the project into
sub tasks that are actually act as sub
projects
and implementing this mindset changing
our mindset to do that we'll be able to
scale our work by dividing the tasks
between different team members that will
be independent
one from the other and conquer our
project simultaneously making us move to
production much more faster
so wait
you're probably gonna ask me another
question so how can we build the model
without processing
well this is where the minimum valuable
pipeline the mvp term comes into play so
each step depends only on the output of
the previous one so for example the
modeling step will probably need the
output of the processing step and this
is why we'd like to open the bottleneck
by producing this mvp and have each type
test start working on its tasks
independently from other text tasks
and once a team reaches a valuable
product they simply update the version
they have in the master branch and the
let's say the modeling team will choose
if to use the new processing
method or the old one
and implementing this workflow will
change our
directory or project to look like this
so each
subtask is going to have its own
subdirectory which is going to be
a python module
with its own uh notebook so we're going
to take our long long long notebook and
we're going to break it down to sub
notebooks and it's also gonna have its
own subscripts that are relevant to this
specific uh um sub project or step okay
so we're gonna have the eda we're gonna
have the data processing etc
and by implementing the mono
reconstructor
in three main capabilities so first and
foremost we're able to scale the number
of collaborators on the project and
increase our product and move to
production each time faster
and moreover we're gonna have shorter
notebooks that are task oriented and
this is also something that is very
important we don't want to have a very
very long notebook so if you remember
it's very hard to debug it's very hard
to maintain and by having a task
oriented notebook it's going to make it
very it's going to make it much more
easier to maintain to review and to
debug and this is extremely important
and also
now our project is going to have a clear
structure making the onboarding of the
project or the handoff of the project to
a different
different much more
clearer and easier
and now that we mentioned that we're
going to collaborate with other people's
other people or other teammates so this
means uh uh or or in my intuition it has
uh on it rings only one belt
version control and in this case we
should use git to do so and if you have
second saw second thoughts about uh if
you should use git or not so still
use git and if someone tells you listen
git is not the right tool for data
scientists then just don't listen to
them they're probably giving you bad
advices
git is the standard in the industry and
it's great for modeling parallel work
and i promise you that eventually it
will save your life you will be able to
reproduce your previous result as like
that so with a click of a button
and by using git we can work in parallel
in isolated environments so we can
prevent collaborators from stepping on
each other's toes we can recover
previous work we can use standard ci cd
tools and the list just goes on and on
and on and on git is simply awesome
and now that we mentioned uh version
control
what about other uh non-code artifacts
that we have in our project aren't they
important or as important as our code
files so let's say that in our example
the data processing team created a new
data set should they just override the
old version or maybe a stone age version
it by creating a new directory and
giving it a meaningful name so i argue
that both options are very bad
and this is why we'd want to also
version all of the large files or
components that we have in our project
and now another question that you might
ask yourself
okay so why not simply use git for this
task well git was designed to manage
software development project and
versioning test or text or code files
therefore git doesn't handle large files
very well
so another question might be so why not
use git lfs for this test well git lfs
is better than git for managing large
files but when scaling it fails
and another thing that both git and git
lfs are not optimized for data science
workflows
and to overcome this challenge a lot of
powerful tools uh emerged in recent
years such as dvc delta lake dole leki
fest and many many many more and at that
sub we're integrated with dvc which i
think is awesome because first and
foremost it's open source and we believe
that it's very important it also
provides additional capabilities such as
pipeline supporting many cloud providers
such as google azure and many more and
also they have a great community so i
highly recommend using dvc but really
it's a it's a matter of taste and it's
up for you to decide how you want to or
with what tool you want to version your
large files
and once we get a version all of the
project components we'll have our code
our data models all version under a
single git commit
making us reproduce our large files with
a click of a button
and also we'll be able to share our
large files within the team
much more easily so we don't need to
tell them listen go to this director
with this name we can simply either send
them share them a link or give them the
git commit that refers to the specific
version that you want to send them
okay so next component so
now that we moved our codes into
functions it's make it it makes it much
more easier to control the input they
get and this help us to control the
configurations of every run
and track the hyper parameters of every
experiment easily
therefore we want to uh
to take or to move the configurations
that we're using for each stage to an
extended file and then simply import
them as
uh variables
and in this case i'd highly recommend
using a haida which once again also it's
open source so it's great in my opinion
but also they're very good in
managing configurations for a large
scale project and i think they're
awesome but once again up to you to
decide
and but you can probably imagine that
tracking each experiment with git and
every even every set of hyper parameters
can become a hassle so you need to git
commit git add etc or git add and then
git commit
which is going to be a pain so this is
why we'd like to automate the logging
process of our experiment for each run
the same is for large files uh there are
a lot of tools that emerge in recent
years for experiment logging such as
weights and biases and flow neptune
tensorboard and many more and in this
case i think that it doesn't really
matter with which hammer you choose to
uh punch the or hit the name as long as
you punch it through and i think that in
this use case the best thing would be to
mix and match between the git
logging and the
external experiment tracking
and by implementing this we can easily
understand the research history and
enable other people to review the high
level results we can reproduce
experiment to some extents very easily
and we can avoid at all
our experiment which will probably uh be
will vary between different team members
and just before we move into production
we'd like to make sure that uh we're
checking two very important boxes so the
first one will be before we deploy in
our model to production we'd want to
move all of the logic stored in the
notebook to python script
so we're gonna take it can be a sequence
of cells or just a single cell
the what matter here is that it's gonna
have the same logic and we're gonna move
it to outside to python script and then
import it back to our jupiter notebook
and by implementing this flow we will uh
only use in productions we're going to
only use skips in production which are
the industry standard and which will be
much more easier to handle we will have
only one code base that we need to
maintain so only the scripts
and will be also be able to still use
notebooks and utilize their advantages
and a split second that before we're
gonna merge our project to master don't
forget to write unit tests so the sender
in software development we'd like to
make sure that our code does whatever it
was designed to do
and it goes with visualization data
processing and even modeling so for
example let's say that our model
classifies images of cats and dogs so
you want to test it performances and see
how it works with an image of a
chihuahua and make sure that it works
properly
and we all know that unit testing can
take or can consume a lot of our time
therefore we'd like to make sure that
we're writing them only uh for code that
goes in production so my two cents here
will be don't rush yourself into writing
them
and by implementing this flow we'll
probably get fewer bugs in production
which will increase our sleeping time
so by that we reach to the end of this
session um and if i have to sum the last
30 minutes into one sentence it will be
try to or develop your code
for a notebook and don't develop it in a
notebook
so from the get-go you need to think
how about the end goal which is
deploying to production and what will
help you later on to reduce the
iteration time to production
and while reducing the risks of bugs in
production so moving to python scripts
that are much more easier to test and
easier to deploy writing unit tests um
version all of our project components
all of this should be in our mindset
when we're starting to work on our
projects from the get-go
and it will later on help us to deploy
our model to production much more faster
and then iterate over it to improve our
results and um it will be much more easy
so
with that we made it on time just a
split second before uh 12.
so i want to thank you all for joining i
know that we're short on time so if you
have uh any questions i'd love to answer
them uh on the slack channel so please
you can refer them uh uh on dm to me so
my name is nick babazida you're more
than welcome to also uh connect me on
linkedin or twitter and ask it there
and i really want to thank you all for
joining and seeing such a big turnout
it's it's amazing
thank you so much junior for being with
us so as we're very short on time we
have one minute left so i don't think we
can open two questions what i would
recommend please continue the
conversation you can go to a slack other
option you can also go together now and
have a more of a conference feeling up
to you near thank you so much for being
with us and presenting at pi data global
thank you so much thank you so much it's
great being here uh and pi data is
it's amazing so we have a branch here in
israel and i we i i'm joining each
meeting each meetup uh so i want to
thank you for doing this amazing things
that you're doing worldwide and i see
all the thanks and uh great sessions so
i'm honored and really thank you all and
feel free to dm me reach me on linkedin
i'm here and i would love to chat and
listen to your issues that you're facing
and how we can overcome that
and check out
[Laughter]
thank you so much
bye